[Music]
I want to hear your voice I want to hear
people's voices for whatever reason
Philadelphia is a bit of a quiet city on
the street they're you know they're
people don't honk their horn so much the
city streets traffic doesn't zoom past
like in a lot of cities but if you go
inside especially in the cafes and bars
and restaurants it's one of the noisiest
sins I've ever been to about which is
great it means that people are talking
and enjoying and arguing that's a great
sound to record
I'd be interested to hear sounds from
your voice if I ask like what's our
democracy like today hmm
yes where's the city going over there
over the next five years even by saying
the word Philadelphia Philadelphia
Philadelphia Philadelphia Philadelphia
anything your voice tells me so much
tells all of us so much about what
you're feeling and what you care about
so the here Philadelphia app is
available now you can get it on the App
Store or Google Play it's for free just
download it and use it I encourage you
to go out and record sounds and voices
now as soon as you can the sounds are
coming in from all over Philadelphia I'm
collecting them listening to them all
the time I've got to collect everything
and start putting this all together into
a symphony by the beginning of December
the more that you can send before
Thanksgiving the better it is for the
piece and i truly appreciate it so go
out and listen go out and make sound go
out and sing right into the hereit here
philadelphia app send them to me and I
will make this do this Philadelphia
cheesesteaks do of music and rhythms and
words and some sounds and stories I hope
through Philadelphia
lenz will give an idea of what democracy
started out as what's at stake right now
and what kind of society we don't want
you
[Music]